everybody I just posted an Instagram
post for your phone number this is the
first call and ask Gary Vee
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
live in LA even that even that I think
brings a lot of value to this askgaryvee
show fills here which is super weird and
I'm I'm pretty damn excited about a
dirac always loves new stuff obviously
if you've been paying attention over
last week there's been a lot of changes
in the social media ecosystem and I've
been tripling down on an Instagram world
we've been doing a ton of things on a
60-second Club dailyvee has gone daily
and that has been quite intense and a
lot of fun and most of all the Facebook
excuse me the Instagram live feature
just post in and we played a little bit
around with that but I was sneaking on
this one right I just trying to be
sneaky at it and there's been a lot of
pressure internally for me of not doing
the askgaryvee show and I think one of
the things that's important is always
evolving and tile you can start dialing
right now I think what's really exciting
is that we are now going to a call-in
show format for askgaryvee show so go
ahead do your thing and so all I'll need
is for you to tell me the phone number
you can go louder don't worry what's
that that's not that's not what you do
you do this there you go just teaching
Tyler how to use a phone
and so what we're going to be doing now
is we're going to be posting for your
phone number on Instagram if you're not
following me on Instagram all right got
to get through the kinks one anyway
we'll see how long it takes Tyler to
post a phone number but we're pushing an
Instagram your phone numbers go in there
we call you come and ask for a question
and we do it just like a live and call
and radio show same thing you'd be doing
is you were posting but here with a
little bit feedback here we go what's
the name and huh Anton and here we go
folks
well it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you oh
I'm great okay are you I'm doing good
Anton you are the first caller on the
askgaryvee show live call-in show how do
you feel about that that's awesome I was
just thinking about you what I want to
ask but first of all I just wanted to
tell you that there is a great
opportunity for you for your company
there is a Russian businessman in Russia
who has a 50 cell bank in Moscow and he
has a 150 K dollars song competition for
a company used on marketing company
called make an aspirin so I just felt
like Anton I don't I don't know I don't
get out of bed for at least 150 1000
I'll take a look you can send me an
email nap but for the show I got to keep
it tight this is a good framework for
everybody obviously everybody's gonna
want to save their things for keeping it
tight we'll go right into the question
what question can I answer pretty
brother I just wanted to ask you what
you think is the most critical thing for
people who come up out of military you
know and try to yes yes that's a great
question it's and thank you so much for
that I'll let you um I'll uh do this
good that's how we got to do it you got
to do like that like like the call-in
radio shows and how great question the
others way but I might want to keep it
I'll make those decisions uh and Anton I
think when you make a transition from
military to the private sector you've
got to readjust to the new framework so
many people struggle with transition
from whether it's the education system
the military system the government
system into the private sector where the
market controls where you have
bureaucracies and these big machines
they're not always playing by market
dynamics so the biggest transition is
understanding the market is in control
not your general not your general
general not your boss's boss not the
bureaucrats not the politicians no no
the market and so to me when you go into
the private sector understanding that
now obviously within an organization or
corporation which is more similar to
those dynamics you'll play those
politics but if you go into
entrepreneurship it's a whole different
game the market gets to decide and
understanding that the way you've had it
before is not the way you're going to
have it forward is extremely important
you've got to be prepared for that
market dynamic way too many people
getting punched in the face by the
market go ahead and not being able to
adjust and so I think that to me is what
stands out as the biggest vulnerability
of people transitioning from the
military very structured system one that
they go through this you know the scales
of the organization and then going into
the private sector especially
entrepreneurship it is a wild wild west
opportunity who are we talking about
here rim sing bread askgaryvee calling
show Oh red Gary yes this is Gary
Vaynerchuk do no wait go crazy
welcome to the askgaryvee show what can
I answer for you oh wow I didn't think I
was gonna get the phone call friend ran
the point of this was you put up putting
out the numbers it's for the askgaryvee
show you got to have your question ready
baby I know I know it's okay with me how
well I do on the spot I like it where
you why don't we do this while I buy you
some time rent where are you from um
well originally I'm from Estonia very
nice I live in Seattle Washington right
now very nice big day for Seattle here
obviously the big contest winner who's
going to shadow me from the day was from
Seattle Wren what question can I answer
for you
alright so almost 21 years old I'm going
to school even though I know I should
just be doing business or becoming an
entrepreneur how do i what do you think
you finished go and do it or what do you
think well let's let's break it down why
are you staying in school are you doing
it for your parents are you doing it for
yourself or do you still have some
thoughts that an education is a good
backup plan like what's what's your
truth don't [ __ ] me Wren honestly a
self doubt and that's it I love you for
that that's I love you so much rent for
that so now the question becomes why
you have that what do you have in your
history that creates that have you been
able the one thing that allows kids to
make the jump if they have self-doubt is
if they have a history of making money
what allowed me to never be scared was I
knew I could make a dime
have you had selling or entrepreneurial
background as a teenager as a kid have
you ever made money selling [ __ ] oh oh
yeah I was like in third grade my
friends were playing outside and my
family didn't have money so I was mowing
lawn and like mowing lawns watching cars
and doing all that stuff I used to get
in trouble in middle school because I
used to sell candy bars during class
Brent let me ask you a question are you
willing to live in your parents home or
somewhere else like real super ghetto
basement like with seven friends like do
you need to be fancy because you want to
hook up and play that part or do you
want to be like if it's burning you
inside and you're willing to live very
humbly and eat [ __ ] food for a while and
not have fancy things and just work on
your business then you can make that
jump you know that's really what it
comes down to mm-hmm yeah I know a lot
of people say that they would but I know
myself and I would be fine I mean when I
went to my first year in college I was
debating on sleeping in my car just as
his tuition money so I could open
something up listen run I mean to be
very honest just even going through this
talk I think you win either way if you
want to take these next couple years
work out your doubt issues and maybe get
into a place where you can you can feel
can you answer that question because I
got tired out of the show and you cannot
you know if you want to work out those
issues and get into a place where you
have some fun and not have that
responsibility and you want to go out
and party and things that nature I think
that's super fine but I also think that
asking you those questions I think
you're in a place you can't tell them I
need 15 minutes let them know I think
you're also in a place where you'll be
okay if you make that jump I think
you're in a good spot either way I like
your vibe all right man did you can let
me take on Jerry yeah I know it you
probably gotta go but yes one day I'm
gonna meet you man have lunch with you I
don't know how it went but it's gonna
happen I hope so run good luck to you
man thanks all right man thank you look
bright red keep going keep going
you can lower it out a little bit
actually it's fine um this would be fun
I think this brings a totally different
dynamic it gives extra layers of context
to the show I'm really enjoying you got
breaking things dear
look at this dailyvee and askgaryvee
going into 2017 both format changes
Julie totally different format changes
to format changes going into 2017 this
isn't eating my own dog food you've got
to put yourself out of business I have
two successful shows and I'm breaking
them to make them better I love it and I
can go back if this format doesn't work
for you I can go back well Julie's gonna
lose here
Julie Ramirez Julie Julie Mon greenus no
no leave this is my favorite part Lori
reach that doesn't sound like Julie
alright next oh wow
there's some dog action going on out
there I like it done let's go let's go
ty maybe quicker on the trigger while I
try to you know create no silent space
here daily be afraid to Atlanta should
definitely check that out
subscribe to uh to Instagram
notifications if you have not done that
I'm telling you you're gonna miss out on
a ton of stuff in my world what do you
got here Sammy
all right see what Sammy's question is
going to be on the askgaryvee show live
calling show Sammy its Gary V Gary this
is awesome bro
and you were on the show uh-huh I got a
question for you let's go go right into
it Sammy and then my question is I've
you don't have to make a business
decision that might mess up your
friendship or yeah we're partners with
someone yep you know you Vicky yeah poor
infant and how did you deal with that
man yep so uh I've had a lot of them I
was in business with my dad and I knew
that I wanted to do other things and
that was insane of the thought of
leaving that I uh my friend Charles
Pearson was one of my best friends when
I was running my business and I had to
fire him
and he was one of my best social friends
I had to fire him because he wasn't
bringing it and he was doing things that
were taking advantage of our friendship
and he didn't think I was a meritocracy
vaynermedia currently has a lot of
family member at both my brother laws
now involved I have tons of AJ's friends
all of them are being
if you were unable to treat business for
business your business will die and so
that's okay because sometimes you may
want to pick your friendship over that
business and that's fine
but yes I've been in a lot of those
situations and I think that especially
with friendships
you're good you're going to either
create cancer from the situation or
you're going to fix the situation you
don't understand if there's friction
from your end it's already a lost
situation either you're gonna fire you
have to deal with that person or breakup
or whatever you're talking about and
that person is affected by it or you're
going to eat [ __ ] and it's going to turn
into a cancer cell internally in the
business and yourself and eventually
it's going to reap its head and you're
gonna have an issue got it so you've
already lost you might as well get the
bad part over with quickly so that the
business can survive that loss that's
exactly what I needed - you're
guaranteed we got us a me take care this
is a TV show this is going to be a good
show fail this is gonna be a good show
do you think you may have to be in every
episode talking about your venture
capital love who's this this is Levi
rain Levi this is so fun Gary [ __ ] V
Levi you are on the show
oh man that's crazy okay okay I need to
tell you that little bit good real fast
yeah I'll be quick okay so I was on the
on the Instagram vibe I don't even know
you do that but the crazy thing about
that like just think about how I'm
saying it is that you can like put a
camera to your face show someone else
where you're at like why that's crazy to
me I totally agree man I think people
under estimating the technology
revolution like going live to thousands
of people was something that cost
millions of dollars and only a few
people could do just a decade and a half
ago and so it's incredible it leads to
stuff like this I mean look what's going
on here all this is so interconnected
I went live then a meeting got canceled
then I'm like hey D Rock let's go do the
askgaryvee show then I post on Instagram
phone numbers then we call you and now
Levi you're on the show oh yeah
I was like the whole like 50 minutes of
you just calling people and I don't know
a lot of it was really entertaining
fairytale McHale this is Gary Vaynerchuk
goddamnit I don't shop dasu
yeah thanks mother stuff I'm reading
that Jab Jab right hook right now thank
you thank man what's your question
brother my question okay so I have a
like a career but my career I get like
four days on or four days off and what I
want to do is like if I think is market
like we have restaurants around where I
live in the Portland area come on don't
even have a Facebook page enough crazy
community because like it's just old
people running the restaurant you know
they like yep I feel like if they would
give me a chance to like go on their
Facebook on their Instagram right let me
give you let me give you leave I let me
give you a great piece of advice do it
for free at first have five clients and
then you can use them to show other
people the amount of people they're not
willing to do stuff for free at first to
create case studies Phil Toronto in this
room right now runs is my right-hand man
and all my investments what did he do he
interned for free for a long time d-roc
made a free film right made a free film
and now he's d-roc right a Tyler run
Tyler but anyway I leave I you got it
you've got to go free on this go and do
to Italy when you're doing whatever
you're doing
whoever you like the most when you're in
the restaurants you like like the couple
you think they're sweet offer to do the
service is free they become your case
studies then you charge 100 bucks a
month thank you charge 500 bucks a month
then you build a business people aren't
willing to eat [ __ ] in a 20-17 world and
that's why so many people's businesses
haven't started awesome that's great
advice
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna go out and
look keep me updated home call back in
in a month keep me updated love you see
ya alright I got I like Levi this is fun
what we got tie sorry I said by the way
this is just for the episode my sister
just texted me I'm just gonna say her
lover
well I wait for this Oh to go let's go
ty gotta be way faster time can be way
faster you know I mean yeah guy get more
Levi's on there sorry just got
distracted how to say what's up to my
sis she's doing great
um and big shout-out to max I'm Hannah
my niece and nephew my sis aside
Dustin Riggle Dustin riddle Zach and
Dylan on the other side hello Dustin
yeah this is Gary Vee and you're on the
show Oh what is your question you know
what I don't have a question what I want
to say is this go ahead I've been
following you for probably three years
now
and I can't tell you how many times I
get emotional watching you post you are
so down to earth you're just the most
women dude that I've ever come across
and I look up to you like no other I
really I just want to say thank you
thank you so much at it I appreciate you
if I ever get the opportunity to shadow
you ever work for you whatever it may be
but we'll do it live great question live
clear well I have great news once a
quarter four times a year on the
60-second Club I'm gonna give away the
shadow so look out for that okay thank
you very much you got real great love
you pal thank you for that that meant a
lot to me
all right listen we need to establish
the rules for the call and show now we
have a real connection and I I feed off
your feedback in your love and you guys
know that you're starting to figure me
out I live for that feedback for that
engagement for the love I do I've got
mine I don't need you I don't need your
courses I don't even need you buying my
books to be very frank I really I really
don't I've got my back advances up front
I really don't what I need is what I
need is the community and so some of you
are figuring that out and that's why
phone calls like that happen and so I
appreciate it but for the cup we can do
that different times we'll do
I'm Collins but when we do the
askgaryvee show if you're gonna put your
number in instagram form if you're gonna
if you're gonna leave your phone number
in the in the comments you're gonna have
to have a question because i think i
want to do right by it I can listen I
feed off of just all day long tie pick a
[ __ ] number what do you do what do
you when you're doing your break in the
show is what you're doing I'm doing
something here I mean but we need one
more I mean she's all right we're gonna
have to clearly bring India back um so
so ground rules for this new Colin show
you've got to have a question I'll take
the love we'll intermix it but I really
want to bring value to the community and
really a great thing that the
vaynernation can do think about
questions that are uniquely for
everybody to or frame them in that way
who's this Gio Soto GL are you going
International trice international one
will do a whole international show we
got a statement or mixed international
come on Gio you have reached the
voicemail ha
uh-huh don't do that I wanted the name
d-roc you're not in control of phone I
know you get you get I've watched your
roles let's go talk real fast
I've watched you roll for the last year
or two you like it in your hands in a
lot of places I love that about you
you're a full pledged Swiss Army knife
but if you ever hang up on the phone
again I'm gonna rip your fingers off cuz
I definitely wanted to see was gonna say
Gio if it would start with a number I
would have turned it off just to give
you a little tell this is mine that is
yours
I don't touch your camera who's this
hello originator this is Gary Vee and
you're on the show are you I'm dead
serious my number now get out of those
two thousand Armand that won't be
another number well guess what it's not
and you've got your shot to ask me a
question what do you got my man Wow
actually just forgot the question well
let's do it this way I'll buy you a
second what do you do for a living or
what what's your life up to our
liturgies graduated from college oh I
remember how that I just graduated from
college two days ago with the
well congratulations my man what's your
question so I applied to a lot of places
and I actually tried that plat a
vaynermedia yep but I was trying to
figure out how Dietetic stands up a lot
of companies that supports days I think
yeah I think one of the you know this is
the advice and theme in the show I got
to tell you man I don't think it's a bad
idea to work for free or an internship
or or get a job and at night at night
from 7:00 well let's work backwards what
do you want to do what do you apply for
for vaynermedia the ACC roll that
entry-level roll yeah I want to do a ear
media analyst okay so here's what I
would say where do you live in Richmond
Virginia I love it so everybody watching
any askgaryvee show if you have a
company that needs media analysts please
leave a comment below in YouTube or
Facebook so he can check that out but
number two listen to me listen to me
good reach out to 50 to 100 businesses
in the Richmond Virginia area that have
those roles or needs and tell them that
you're willing to intern for free or
work after hours in it or look for
startups because there's a ton in the
Richmond Virginia area
tons of startups will take your 7 p.m.
to 10 p.m. hustle so you get a job that
pays the bills and pay your scooter
loans or whatever you've got I've got to
be empathetic to the practicality but
then you go and switch from 7:00 p.m. to
10:00 at night and you go work for free
and a startup and that becomes the
experience that you use to get a job in
what you want to do my man the biggest
what's your what's your first name and
Andrew my man listen to me the biggest
problem with a lot of players that are
young today is their fancy they're not
willing to back up their ambition so if
you want this if you want to be a mini
analyst if you want to control your
narrative if you can't get a job by
applying then you've got to go to plan B
and Plan B is to go work at a start-up
for free from 7:00 to 10:00 p.m. so you
build your resume and we crush it there
and you're so great they'll probably
offer you a full time job got it I just
literally got put on you like two weeks
ago and I've watched so much content my
brother just put me on I put my friends
on and I'm telling everybody
Vivi's every single day I appreciate
milena to your god I love the man I wish
you well
take care all right I think it's good
that feels
you want to sneak one more in alright go
real fast you got one you're feeling
good one of my favorite Chuck's of all
time just asked me if I was available on
text uh Tyler really upset this better
be good ty I love that man yeah Joe
Angelica international national no okay
national hello Angelica yeah this is
Gary B and you are on the show what god
I am not kidding oh do you have a
question um you know honestly I've
decided you uh as I want to do I've got
so many things in my brain right now
we're starting up our new so it's all
good Oh company I don't really have a
question because I honestly did not
think you would call me and I'm freaking
out right now
come on let's manufacture one for the
show come up with something even if it's
basic okay okay um but I me on I've
given me like so much motivation I have
zero I mean we're starting off with like
nothing you know that's good I'm going
just locally right now what I do for a
comfort company houston like you there I
might quick now you do look uh faint
like social meet that you know yeah yeah
you're doing community management for
local businesses in Houston right but
I'm actually in Dallas so what I'm gonna
do what we're doing is we're creating
our own companies and we're gonna go
locally I've already got a couple cool
days I'm going to talk to you and it's
going to basically um why not you know
one by one try to build this myself
so here's let me give you some advice
couple things when you don't have a
money when you don't have lots of
funding or money and you're starting at
zero you've got time your asset and so
many people who are listening
right now that want to do what they want
to do they have time time is their
currency and your hustle right so right
you watch a little less garyvee you
watch a little less Netflix you watch a
little less Dallas Cowboys you do a
little bit less yoga or whatever the
hell is your life is about and what you
do is you go and ask for business but if
you get a bunch of nose you convert very
quickly in doing one or two or three pro
bono pick ones do the work for free but
pick ones that are big and will give you
exposure and you giving free work will
give you leverage of the logo getting
you other work got it right right that's
perfect I mean exactly our first night
that's what we're doing we're not love
it asking for word is asking for
basically you know word of mouth yep the
logo you got it and to get it going well
then you are then you are well on your
way
Congrats us good money boy well I
appreciate make it make a 23-7 Gary Vee
I love it
have a great holiday you ever done bye
bye and that's it the first episode of
the askgaryvee show like all in episodes
I think this is the format for me I like
it there's more of that improv thing
going on India dunk your gooses are
cooked and the question of the day is
how would you like to see this format
get better what do we do in this first
episode how do we make a better
vaynernation take over share it up
because the more shares in the Facebook
environment the more my juices get going
pretty funny that way you keep asking
questions on the phone and I'll keep
answering them
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B